well I reject the term post-racial it's
kind of scares me in the sense that I
never want that to happen to America
let's not sanitize homogenized deodorize
our country dear God we're not a
homogeneous country like Norway or
Holland nor do I want us to be not
there's anything wrong with that but I
want to be America we are America
because we have strong Italian
communities steeped in who they are or
Irish communities with the pride of that
community Korean Mexican Haitian
Nigerian we are the United States of
America which is a wonderful collection
of so many different races ethnicities
and religions and god forbid we ever get
to a point where we quote/unquote
transcend our race what makes America so
rich so powerful stroke so strong is our
diversity and I want to be a person that
is Who I am fully I want to be a guy
who's from New Jersey I got my Jersey
pride laughed at my Bruce and my Queen
Latifah and but I also want to be a guy
who was a Christian I don't want to that
shouldn't be something I should have to
apologize for and I want to be a black
guy you know I'm an African American
that comes with a certain culture from
from the food I ate to the to the music
I listened to my father's you know
Charlie Parker records or Earth Wind and
Fire
all these things that are part of the
african-american experience in culture I
want to look jure 8 in them I want to
enjoy them I want to be proud of my
background and the heritage and Mike
Heritage's contribution to this country
but all of those things ultimately are a
portal for which us to all if we truly
are rooted who we are we eventually
emerge to a deeper understanding of the
humanity a more textured a more rich
understanding there are true
commonalities as a people and that's
where I found out was shmuly on England
and I still never forget we're sitting
there in a drunken spectacle of a Purim
party and the only three people left
standing are the rabbi who's got the
biggest tolerance to alcohol is the
Mormon great guy named Michael Benson
who was the grandson of the Ezra Benson
the head of the
in church this is like the Prince of
Mormonism right here who doesn't drink
and me that the Christian ex football
players never had alcohol the three of
us are sitting there looking at each
other and and and it was this powerful
moment where we're or that where Mike
Benson turns to shmuly an observant warm
and turns to Orthodox Jew and says you
know you being around you and who you
are how fiercely Jewish you are proudly
Jewish you are you've made me a better
Mormon and and surely turns to him and
and says to to Michael it says you know
being around used made me a better a
better a better Jew and I turned to both
of them and said I said hang out with
you guys has done nothing for my love
life but uh but the reality is is that's
what the great thing is about America
the more we understand each other the
more powerfully we celebrate our
culture's that I think the tighter are
buying moms can be and the greater we
bring out the power of humanity so let's
not have my generation of Obama's or
Adrian Fenty s or Artur Davis's or
Harold Ford's these young
african-american guys were coming along
let's let them never symbolize the over
the transcendence of race if anything
let's it celebrates that our country is
becoming a place where all cultures all
ethnicities can get into the into the
center of the arena and fight for a
better America but the thing that you
said about at the end of it though is
this idea that we're beginning to heal
the racial pains of the past that were
being in to address the racial
disparities of the past and that's a
that's a good question or a good point
really what is happening in America a
generation since the civil rights
movement especially for leaders in our
generation who weren't alive in 68 67 66
65 and for well a lot of that action was
what's happening what does this really
mean and the first thing I say is it you
know looking at an Obama you know
harvard-educated lawyer or arctor davis
another Ivy League a lawyer or Harold
Ford and another person with great
professional credentials in many ways it
is a celebration that our ancestors
opened up these incredible doors before
even a larger flow of
freaking Americans Latinos and other
minorities and women to get
opportunities but they didn't get two or
three generations ago in America and it
of itself is a wonderful thing but we as
a country stuff a lot of work to do you
know there's kids in Newark that stand
it up and stood up this morning and and
uttered something that people in Beverly
Hills did the same kids they stood up
and said the exact same things that we
are one nation under God indivisible I
love that I deal with liberty and
justice for all
to me those words are still aspirational
we haven't achieved them yet you don't
have to go far to see disparities we can
you could challenge anybody and I've
done this in audiences all the time I
said you know everybody here knows who
Jon Benet Ramsey is and Natalie Holloway
privileged girls who happen to be white
who were murdered it became national
scenes but in the cities like Newark
they're unsolved murders of black
children that don't capture the same
kind of national sensation and you have
to wonder why is that you look at racial
disparities in incarceration in New
Jersey for example fourteen percent of
our population is African American over
60% of the prison population is black
look at racial disparities in so many
different areas we have not become a
country that reflects our ideals yet
nobody black or white Latino or Asian
can say that we have achieved it yet so
if anything this next generation of
African Americans leaders or Latino
young leaders or whatever ethnic group
well we have to realize is why we have
benefited so lavishly from the
sacrifices of our of our parents we have
a larger obligation to continue their
struggle and not give up on the highest
ideals of America that we can become
that country that our children speak to
every single morning and that is what
excites me most is that you see a guy
like Barack Obama or whomever expressing
that unbelievable commitment that same
kind of fire that same kind of hope and
optimism and belief that we can be this
nation that as king would say I've been
to the mountaintop and I could see the
promised land that we will get to that
promised land